- Good afternoon.
My name is Immaculata
De Vivo, and I
am the Interim Co-director for
Science Programming this year
for the life sciences.
And I am delighted
and privileged to be
introducing our speakers today.
The lecture is entitled
"Science Sounds Strange,"
and it's actually the first
lecture in the Undiscovered
Science Series.
The Undiscovered Series,
or the actual conference,
will be held on October 26.
And the conference itself
showcases the critical role
of unexpected or unforeseeable
discovery in science.
And my co-partner, Lisa Goodman,
this was her brainchild.
The goal of that day is to
gather not only scientists
but educators, students,
and journalists,
media producers,
and others to start
a new, very public conversation
about how scientists
should make discoveries.
Today, I am privileged
to present Professor John
Huth, who is a Donner
Professor of Science
in the Department of Physics
here at Harvard University.
He served as the faculty
co-director of science
at this Institute, at
Radcliffe, and he works mainly
in the field of experimental
particle physics.
I also would like to introduce
our thereminist, Dorit
Chrysler, who's sitting
in the front row.
She's an Austrian-born
thereminist.
She's a composer,
producer, and singer.
And her focus is to promote the
theremin in contemporary music.
I actually did a
little research myself
so that I wouldn't
sound too foolish today.
And I found out
that this instrument
is one of the only
instruments that can be played
without actually touching it.
So yes.
She's also the founder of
the New York Theremin Society
and started America's
first school
for theremin,
KidCoolThereminSchool.
She has performed with the San
Francisco Symphony Orchestra
and is featured on the
soundtrack of the HBO
documentary, Going Clear.
She's been commissioned for
MoMA in the Venice Biennial,
and she's performed at Lincoln
Center, Vienna, Coachella--
just a whole variety
of different venues.
And I guess,
without further ado,
I'd like to present Professor
John Huth to the podium.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
- OK.
Well, welcome.
Actually, Dorit is the
main speaker and performer
on the theremin.
So the way we're going
to do it is Dorit's going
to come up, explain the
theremin a little bit,
perform some pieces, and also
talk about the amazing and odd
life of Leo Theremin.
And at some moment,
she'll ask me to come up,
and I'll give you some of the
physical principles underlying
the performance of the theremin
and some of the espionage work
that Theremin was engaged in.
So Dorit.
[APPLAUSE]
- Thank you, John.
Thank you for having me.
Some years ago, I was invited
at a friend's house in New York.
And he pointed me
towards a very unassuming
looking object consisting of
a wooden box with a metal rod.
Some power was plugged in.
And then suddenly, I heard
a really unusual and strange
sound that seemed to
correlate with the slightest
motion of my body.
And I was instantly smitten
and surprised that I had never
heard about this
device that turned out
to be a music instrument.
And I wanted to find
out, how does it work?
How can it be played?
And why is this instrument
not more popular?
So this was my first
encounter with the theremin.
And I would like
to know who of you
here has ever played
a theremin before?
OK.
We have a few arms-- about
10, which is not bad.
But it should be more.
[LAUGHTER]
- [INAUDIBLE]
- OK.
Yeah.
The theremin really came
to life by accident.
It was invented-- created--
by a Russian physicist,
Lev Theremin.
He was working at the time
at the Physical Technical
Institute in St. Petersburg.
And he was working
on the principle
of one of the first
motion detector systems.
And he actually
created an alarm system
that was installed
at the Moscow Bank,
and it's based on a principle
that, then, John later
will more elaborately
explain to all of us.
All I can do is demonstrate this
alarm system that he created--
just basically created
the electromagnetic field
and the body.
[ELECTRONIC WHIRRING NOISE]
Approaching a certain
distance, the body
is a conductor
changing the frequency
and creating a sound
in the audible range.
When he worked on this
in the laboratory,
strange noises emerged.
And because Lev Theremin
also was a cellist,
he had the idea to turn
this principle into a music
instrument, hence the theremin.
The theremin, of course,
is a completely different
musical interface than all
the traditional instruments.
And that, and for
many other reasons,
it really had problems
establishing itself.
It's also extremely hard
to play because it responds
to the slightest
motion of the body,
even when you think
you're not moving.
You still are
constantly in motion,
and it changes the pitch.
When you play theremin, you
really dive into micro-space.
Because of this invention-- it
was the era of electrification
in the Soviet Union.
It was 1919, meaning the
theremin is turning 100
next year.
And he became a prodigy of
Lenin with this instrument.
There's a nice photo
where Lenin himself
is playing the theremin.
And he was sent across
Europe to promote
the technical
achievements of Russia.
And he made it all
the way to New York.
And there, he had
his first review--
1927-- by The New York Times.
There was a headline that
said "Ether Wave Music Amazes
Savants."
And it featured an
interview by Lev Theremin
where he quotes verbatim--
very humbly-- he
says, "My apparatus
will liberate the
composer of the despotism
of the well-tempered
12-tone piano scale.
It offers infinite tonal
possibility and literally
thousands of tone colors."
To give you now a possibility
to make your own impression,
I will perform one of the
pieces that Lev performed
that time, one of the
pieces of his repertoire,
so you can hear for yourself.
[MUSIC - CAMILLE SAINT SAENS,
"THE SWAN"]
[APPLAUSE]
As you can see, one really
has to concentrate and hold
the body very still.
And just two days ago, when
we did something like this,
I was criticized because people
want to know, how do you really
play this?
So I'm just going to give
a very fast explanation.
So you might have noticed
this is the pitch antenna.
So the closer my hand goes
to the pitch antenna--
[ELECTRONIC NOTE PLAYING]
--the higher the note.
And this is the volume antenna.
So the further away, the louder.
And when I have my hand just
above the antenna, it's quiet.
So it's an interplay
of the horizontal
and the vertical fields.
And each note is sculpted in
the air by the volume and tenor
while I'm constantly
intonating and balancing,
as if I'm buzzing
around the flower.
That's the pitch.
And my hand is a
bumblebee, and I'm
trying to land on that
flower to get the pitch.
That's the basic
approach on the theremin.
I just want to talk
a little bit more.
So Lev Theremin
came to New York,
and he made quite a splash
with this new device.
And even though the
theremin, at that time,
was only applied to
classical music, which
really limited its
tonal abilities,
people still were very excited.
And he found some sponsors
and started his laboratory
in Manhattan.
And he also had the
great luck to find
a tremendously talented theremin
virtuoso, Clara Rockmore.
She was a violinist
who injured her hand
and couldn't play
the violin anymore.
And she became a
proficient thereminist that
really set the bar
very high of what
is possible on this instrument.
She then did a lot of tours
with Paul Robeson, activist
and baritone.
And if I could go
back in time, I
would really probably choose
being at one of their concerts
back then.
I think that would have been
really, really exciting.
Theremin sold his patent
for the theremin to RCA.
So that made the theremin the
very first electric instrument
that was actually
mass manufactured.
So it was really the
birth of electronic music.
The only problem was that
RCA marketed the theremin not
really in a very successful
and realistic way.
The theremin was certainly
a luxury item, price-wise.
And they promoted it as a
friendly house instrument,
easy to play for
the whole family,
in the same note
like the home organs.
And obviously, that proved
to be fatally wrong.
In addition, there
was the Black Friday.
The economic crashed.
So that didn't help
things, either.
And Theremin found himself
suddenly in tremendous debt.
And he had himself
established in New York.
He had married
one of the members
of the first African-American
ballet troops.
And suddenly, he was gone.
And there are many rumors.
There's one book
and one documentary,
and there are different
accounts of claiming
that he had been a spy
all along for Russia
and chose to go back.
And others say he was
kidnapped by the KGB.
We don't know what happened.
His wife in the
States didn't know.
He was just suddenly gone.
And we do know that--
Stalin was in
power at that time.
And he was first sent to
Siberia and then ended
in one of those
notorious science camps.
His whole family didn't
think he was alive anymore.
And he worked on technical
devices benefiting the state.
And interesting enough,
he applied the principle
of this instrument also for
another new electronic device,
namely the bug--
"The Thing."
A seal was given by children
to the American Ambassador,
and he hung it right
behind his desk.
And thanks to Theremin's
listening device
that didn't exist until then,
the Russians could listen
into all conversations for
many years until the British
detected a signal.
And there's a very
nice photo when
the UN declared the Cold War.
They're actually holding up
this very seal that contained
the bug that Lev Theremin made.
And so maybe at
this point, I would
like to ask the esteemed
John Huth onstage
to explain the technical
details of all these.
- Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
So Dorit will come up
and talk some more.
But I'll try to explain as
best I can some of the science
between both the
theremin and the bug.
So most people probably
know that like charges
repel in electromagnetism,
and unlike charges attract.
So a plus-minus charge
will attract each other.
A plus charge and a plus
charge will repel each other.
And a minus charge and a minus
So in our bodies, our bodies
are, to some approximation,
saline.
That means it's salt water.
And that means
charges can freely
flow throughout our bodies.
So if I take a charge
and put it on, let's say,
the pitch antenna-- say I put
a bunch of positive charges
on the pitch antenna--
the negative charges
in my body are
going to be attracted
toward the pitch antenna.
And the positive charges
are going to get repelled.
Because the positive charge
here repels the positive charges
in my body and attracts
the negative charges.
And what that does is it creates
a kind of natural device,
if you like, called a capacitor.
A capacitor is simply a
device that holds charge.
This was done by,
among other people,
Ben Franklin, who created
this in a Leyden jar, who
was able to store the charge
from the base of a thundercloud
with a kite to try to figure
out whether there were
positive or negative charges at
the base of the thundercloud.
So the circuit
that's used to get
both the pitch and the volume
involves the following process.
There's another device
inside here called
an inductor, which
sometimes looks
like a little spring wound up.
And that has a property similar
to holding electric charge.
It holds magnetic
fields in some way.
And depending on the
distance your hand is
to either the pitch antenna
or the volume antenna,
you're going to get a different
amount of capacitance.
Now, the way the
circuit works is,
depending on the value
of the capacitance,
there is a natural
frequency that emerges.
And that natural
frequency is the basis
for how you change the
pitch or the volume.
Now, let me explain
this a little bit.
There is almost identical
math in a situation which
is probably more
familiar to you,
which is a child's swing set.
And in the child's
swing set, depending
on the length of the
rope for the swing,
you're going to get a different
frequency that the swing moves
back and forth.
So the longer the rope,
the slower the swing moves.
So the capacitance basically
plays the same role
as the length of the rope
that holds up the swing--
the length of the rope
that holds up the swing.
So that is the main
controlling factor.
So you'll have a
natural frequency
that then gets interrogated.
Now, the big issue is that the
natural frequency associated
with either the pitch or
the volume that comes out
is going to be, typically,
at a radio frequency.
So it's somewhere of
the order of megahertz,
which is well beyond the
range of human hearing.
And the real game is to,
then, take that signal
and convert it into
an audio signal
around the range of
human hearing, which
is 30 hertz to about 20,000
hertz cycles per second.
And to do that, what
Theremin did was he
took a fairly recent
invention, for him,
which was called heterodyning.
And in heterodyning,
what you do is
you introduce a frequency that's
close to the natural frequency
that occurs between the
capacitance of the hand
and the antenna and
the inductor inside.
And then, what that
does is there's
an interference between the
frequency source that you have
inside here and the frequency
that you're naturally creating
by having your hand near here.
And the interference
between the two
will then create a much
lower frequency pattern.
And then, you take that
lower frequency pattern
and turn that into
the sound that
emerges both in controlling the
volume here and the pitch here.
And that's what comes out.
Heterodyning is also
used in FM radio.
Frequency modulation
is probably the term
that you're more familiar
with, whereas the word
heterodyning is kind of
just out in left field.
So more or less,
that's how this works.
Now, the other thing
is how the bug works.
And the bug is kind of
an inverse of the way
the theremin operates.
So let me explain a little bit.
So what you want to do--
I mean, how would you
think about how to do this?
You know, Stalin handed
Theremin this problem,
and he has this bag
of electrical tricks
up his sleeve.
And so you want to
take this plaque that
was given to Averell
Harriman in 1949,
and you want to be able to
listen in on the conversation.
So you have, again, sound
from the human voice,
which is roughly 30
hertz to 20,000 hertz.
But then, you want to convert it
into a radio frequency signal.
OK, so it's the inverse
of what's happening here,
is you're taking something
which is a radio frequency
signal electrically,
turning it into a sound.
So you just invert the problem.
So what Lev did was he
created a kind of circuit,
again, with a capacitor.
And the capacitor, in
this case, one side of it
could vibrate back
and forth associated
with the voice pattern.
So somebody would speak, the
air molecules would vibrate,
and then part of this capacitor
would vibrate back and forth.
The distance between a fixed
plate and this vibrating plate
would change the capacitance.
And it would, again, be part of
the circuit, which is actually
a passive circuit.
There were no
batteries involved.
Because who's going to go
into Averell Harriman's office
and, hey, I got to change the
batteries on the bug, right?
So it has to be
completely passive.
So again, there was this
capacitive inductive circuit
that had a natural frequency.
And that natural frequency
would change a little bit
as you vibrated it.
And this is very much
like the RFID chip.
So for example, in the
transponders in your car
when you go past a
toll plaza, and they
want to know exactly
where your car is,
there are multiple frequencies.
So what happens is that
they beam a radio frequency
signal at your car-- always
beaming there-- but then,
it comes back with a
variety of frequencies
that you can then
look at and uniquely
identify that that's your car.
Marathon runners put these
chips in their shoes,
and you track how they're
going and that sort of thing.
So here, you have
this thing that's
oscillating at a
certain frequency that
is dependent on the capacitance
of that little thing,
the capacitance changing.
And so what the
Soviets then did was
they beamed a radio
frequency signal
towards Harriman's office.
And then, that would create some
interference between the two,
and then it would
naturally rebroadcast out
the signal, which you could then
use to interrogate and find out
what people were saying,
much the same way you
are broadcasting a
signal into the radio
transponder in
your car, and then
you're able to get a unique
signature that's coming back.
So that was the basis of this.
And the way it was
found, of course,
is that, ultimately, this
thing has to rebroadcast out
some sort of signal, the same
way your car's RFID chip would
broadcast out a signal.
And so, ultimately,
people were able to detect
that this radio frequency signal
was getting broadcasted out.
And they knocked that out.
And then people started to
look for this sort of thing.
But then, spy versus
spy-- you always
have to come up
with a better idea.
So there was another idea
that the Soviets came up with,
which was to beam a microwave
signal towards the windows,
and the windows would
vibrate back and forth,
and you could listen in doing
that, and on and on and on.
So I could talk about
electronic espionage forever.
But I'm not going to.
And I'll turn it back to Dorit.
But if people have questions
in the question and answer
session, we can address it then.
[APPLAUSE]
- Yeah, so maybe we have
a little bit more time
to just see what
happened to the theremin
after Lev left the
States and disappeared,
working on other
important devices.
In the '30s, composers started
to write for the instrument,
maybe most noted
Messiaen or Percy
Grainger, Robert Schillinger.
And Clara Rockmore did
a very good presentation
as a virtuoso interpreting
the instrument.
Then, in the late '40s,
the theremin, I guess,
reached its most defining,
notorious popularity--
up to now, hopefully--
through Hollywood.
That's a sound you
probably heard but didn't
realize it was a theremin.
It was first, I think,
started in 1947, Spellbound--
Miklós Rózsa wrote
a beautiful score--
the Hitchcock movie.
And whenever Gregory
Peck would have
his memory spells,
the sound of madness,
the theremin lent itself.
The eerie, almost
like a voice quality,
was applied there
very effectively.
And then, it went on from there.
It turned into the
dramatic voice of madness
in The Lost Weekend.
And then, it was discovered
by science fiction and horror
and represented there.
And I would like to maybe
play a piece from that era
by one of my favorite
composers, Bernard Herrmann.
He did the score for The
Day the Earth Stood Still.
And you might have
heard that one before.
[MUSIC - BERNARD HERRMANN, "THE
DAY THE EARTH STOOD STILL"]
[APPLAUSE]
Yeah.
So, yeah.
This is what the theremin is the
most well-known for, I guess.
But fact is it can do
much more than that.
It was then employed by
bands in the '60s and '70s,
most namely the Beach
Boys or Captain Beefheart,
or even Led Zeppelin.
Two days ago, we met Micky
Dolenz of the Monkees.
And my first question to him
was, have you ever played--
do you know the theremin?
And he said, yeah.
I was at the Beach Boys' studio
and played the theremin there.
And so obviously, it
was around at that time.
It's also very interesting
that the theremin is really
often referred to as the
dinosaurs of the synthesizers.
Don Buchla and Bob Moog, who
both were the first people
working and creating
synthesizers,
they always referenced Lev
Theremin and his device.
Don Buchla is quoted as saying
Lev was his big idol because he
is so impressed how he created
the theremin without having
an oscilloscope and
just a few waves.
And Bob Moog started
his first company
when he was 14 building
theremins out of Brooklyn.
And he is still one of
the main producers--
his company-- of theremins.
This is actually a theremini,
kind of a little detour
of the original theremin.
But it's light and
portable, so I like it.
And it's a customized
prototype here.
But this instrument actually
combines the analog interface
of the theremin with
digital technology
by having all these
presets inside.
And it even has a theremin's
worst enemy, pitch control.
So why all this effort if
the pitch is controlled?
But everything you hear from
me is turning all these helpers
off, and I'm only playing
with the very pure [INAUDIBLE]
and setting as it
originally was intended.
Maybe now-- we kind of
landed in the present,
and I want to play a
contemporary composition
so you get a little
bit of an idea,
in addition to melodic playing,
what the theremin can do.
[MUSIC - DORIT CHRYSLER, "RUBIES
AND PEARLS"]
It has a very unique--
[APPLAUSE]
So it has a very
unique weaving quality
that can be applied for a
lot of things, especially,
also, soundtracks.
And I really wish that
more contemporary composers
would write for a theremin.
It has eight octaves.
One of the issues
is that it still
would need a notation
language that
can express all the things the
theremin can do in addition
to just simple melodies.
And we now have more
and more interpreters
that would be capable to
play these compositions.
But we do need the repertoire.
Any questions?
- That's gorgeous, yeah.
I'm a professional musician,
so I have a couple questions.
One is I am assuming that you
cannot play more than one note
at a time with a theremin.
However, I was wondering,
with the foot pedal,
were you processing
things that you were--
and that was not part of the
original theremin, correct?
This is a more modern edition?
And you mentioned notation.
So I was very interested in it.
Because you called
it a composition.
So how is the notation?
How does that-- like the
last piece you played.
You called it a composition.
Thank you.
- Yeah.
So that was a composition.
That was my composition, so I
can take a very free approach.
And that just--
[SCATTERED APPLAUSE]
So I just can take liberties
without a notation system,
because it's my own composition,
without offending the composer.
But yeah, this is one of the
issues that it would need an--
the beauty of the
theremin is that I
think it is a very
interesting tool of expression
and exploring different
sound approaches.
Because it is so physical.
It's literally your
body is the instrument.
And because it is still such a
young instrument, in comparison
with the Greek
hydraulic water system.
They took hundreds
and hundreds of years
to establish themselves.
The sounds that the theremin
is defined through, I think,
has still not been found.
And that's the challenge
and opportunity
for musicians and
composers to dive into that
and establish and
find that and also
be able to write that down.
- So what happens in a typical
theremin society in New York,
and how do the neighbors
react to the noise?
- No neighbor is happy when
someone starts taking up
the theremin, including mine.
But it is doable.
And I encourage--
musicians and non-musicians
have almost an equal
take because it's
such a different way of
rhetorically approaching it,
like any other instrument.
So I think it's a fair game.
The New York Theremin
Society was really
founded as a community platform.
And it turns out there's a
big international community.
And it really tries to promote
the theremin being applied
in different forms of arts.
To give it a proper context,
one of the downfalls, one
of the curses, of the
theremin is that I don't think
there are many other instruments
that so easily can sound
so terrible and unmusical--
like any other instrument.
And so a lot of people
might know the theremin
but permanently
underestimate it and think
it's only capable to kind of--
so it really, the New
York Theremin Society
is one of many
organizations that
try to guard the context
so people really understand
what the instrument can do.
Because it still needs to
be explained, unfortunately.
Thank you.
- I have a question for you
about your playing technique.
I tried a theremin
for all of one day
and stopped because of
complaints from my neighbors.
But like most people
who try a theremin,
usually download a
book by Clara Rockmore
and look at hand positions.
And your technique was
totally different from hers.
And I'm wondering whether you
created your own technique,
whether all good thereminists
develop their own technique,
or whether they all
start with Clara Rockmore
and then move out from there.
- That's a great question.
I think the theremin
right now is
in the stage where the violin
was in the 18th century, where
different schools
started to sprout
in different regions
of the world.
And you actually recognize from
which region the students--
from which teacher--
the students come.
So there are some
players that developed
very specific techniques.
And I have no technique.
And I'm teaching a lot.
So these techniques
of Clara Rockmore--
my take is it really depends
on what you want to do,
what your goal is of
what you want to achieve.
If you want to play
Rachmaninoff or if you want to--
so it depends on that.
And I believe everyone has a
natural, stable hand position.
And this instrument really
does give the opportunity
to develop your own
style and get as
far as you want to get with it.
And if you choose to find
one of the techniques--
which now can be found online--
that might be right for
you, that's OK, too.
So that kind of freedom
really appealed to me
when I started
playing the theremin,
and it might appeal
to others, too.
- I was wondering,
you mentioned bands
like the Beach Boys, and
the Rolling Stones, and Led
Zeppelin, actually, as well.
And I was wondering in
which tracks, notably,
is the theremin used?
Because I've listened
to these bands a lot.
And they all experiment with
sound and do some weird sounds,
but I can never tell if it's
guitar or something different.
So in which tracks is that
the prominent feature?
- That's a good question.
Maybe, John, can you
help me with that?
Do you know?
- Well, Led Zeppelin,
"Whole Lotta Love."
That's the most notable one.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
- Jimmy Page played a
pitch-only theremin.
- We have a Boston
theremin colleague.
- Jimmy Page played a
pitch-only theremin.
It was just one single antenna.
By pitch-only, I mean there
was no volume control.
Beach Boys, most notably,
didn't really use a theremin.
Brian Wilson wanted
that theremin sound.
He didn't care how he got it.
So if you've seen the
theremin documentary, which
Dorit alluded to it--
there's a theremin
documentary that came out
about 20 years ago, I guess--
and they interview
Brian Wilson, and he
talks about getting a theremin.
But really, he just
wanted that sound.
He hired somebody who
said, this is too hard
to play on the theremin.
And the guy invented his own
mechanically controlled--
- [INAUDIBLE]
- Yeah.
And then-- yeah.
It was later dubbed the
Tannerin because the man's name
was Paul Tanner.
And then, on tour, even,
the Beach Boys most recently
used a ribbon-controlled
instrument, as opposed
to a theremin, just because
it's easier to hit those notes.
But that sound was used on
songs like "Good Vibrations"
for that.
[HUMMING]-- that thing.
So that's Led Zeppelin
and the Beach Boys.
But there have been--
lots of bands today are
using the theremin, as well.
- It's kind of hard to tell
these days because most likely,
they're just like Portishead.
They use a mock synthesizer
to simulate the theremin.
- The theremin always
has some imperfections.
If it sounds too good,
it's [INAUDIBLE]..
- Yeah.
You know.
- Actually, I have two parts.
Have you ever had a chance
to play one of the older
original instruments?
And you have a little one.
Have they sampled that?
- This is a great question.
In fact, this is
really interesting
to know for everyone
that likes the theremin.
There are a few of
them floating around,
and there's a
collector in Paris.
And he had an original.
He has all functioning
instruments,
and he had an RCA from
the '20s with the speaker,
and also the Vanguard--
several different theremins
from the '50s that
Bob Moog built.
And trying them out literally
changed my life because--
and it's something I would
like to organize for next year,
for the 100th birthday--
these instruments
make you realize
why there was such excitement
and such promise back then.
Because if you listen to all
the theremin we have now,
they sound like Mickey Mouse.
They sound like tricycles in
comparison with these theremin.
They are like big trucks.
The valves-- they
sound humongous.
They have a fleshy, big sound.
It has, also, a lot to
do with the speakers.
Because fact is,
something that no active
thereminist these days
takes much in consideration,
including myself--
I want to change this ASAP--
is that, actually,
the instrument
consists of the theremin
and its speaker.
And Lev, specifically, also
had the matching speakers.
So that makes all
the difference.
So this is also yet one of
the missing links we still
have to put together.
Great question.
Thank you.
- Hi.
I was wondering if
I or anyone else
here was inspired to start
learning the theremin,
if you would have advice about
where to start or how to start?
- Yes.
Pick a song you really
like, and close your eyes,
and play along to it.
First lesson, learn how the
volume works to not shoot
your frequency range.
And go online and find
out some information.
But we're trying more and more
to offer theremin lectures
and theremin classes.
Because all you really
need is to understand
how to calibrate
a theremin, which
means to set the size of the
pitch and the volume antenna
and how to position yourself
in the most stable position.
And then, you can
really kind of--
if you master one
note perfectly,
you can play the theremin.
And that's a huge challenge.
That might take you a year.
But you're welcome to write.
We're always happy to
give any kind of advice.
But yeah.
I hope this helps.
- Thank you for a
wonderful presentation.
At the beginning of your
performance of "The Day
the Earth Stood Still,"
there was a section
where the sound quality
went from sounding
like what a theremin usually
sounds like to this almost
sound cloud.
What was going on there?
Were you using a pedal?
- Yes.
- Tell me about that.
Very good ears.
I was, because the sound system
here didn't allow me to add
a tiny subtle reverb to kind of
widen and fatten the frequency
like I usually do a little
bit-- we have a very barebone
technical--
but it does the job beautifully.
So that's why I thought
maybe this piece would
be better if I just have--
I was looping it
very quickly and then
realized it's too much, and I
chose to have it clean again.
So I was just experimenting
in the moment of the song.
- There's looping and reverb?
- Yes.
I was creating a very muddy
reverb by a very fast loop.
- I see.
I see.
That was wonderful.
Was that part of the
original-- when you performed
that, was that also how it
was performed for the movie,
or was that something
you introduced?
- No.
No, no, no.
Back then, they really--
that's the interesting thing.
Like a completely
new instrument that's
invented with such dramatic
new tonal possibilities,
and the phenomena of
people not having the--
I'm not ready to really apply
all these new possibilities.
And Lev wanted his
instrument to be
taken serious, understandably,
so he applied it to the most
established music style.
And that limited
it a little bit.
And so that's why it
kind of got stuck.
- Yeah.
Well, that was a revelation.
It was like all the other
theremin music I've heard
is like watching a Lamborghini
go up and down a neighborhood
street.
And when you did that, it just
opened it up and took it out
onto the open road.
So that was really interesting.
Thank you.
- Thank you.
I'm glad.
Yeah.
- So obviously, you need
to have a lot of control
to play the theremin.
Is it possible to play it
with your head or your arm?
- Yes.
So when I started
to teach children--
because I believe
there's not really
much electronic early
music education around,
and children being familiar
with the iPad and all
these interactive things, but
actually physically creating
the sound to motion
and motoric--
it makes so much sense.
And the really little
ones, from four-year-olds,
they bring their favorite
teddy bears, and I ask them,
can you play it with--
so you can play it with
your nose, with your butt--
whichever object, whichever
part of your body is the closest
and shortens the
frequencies-- so it could be--
so infinite possibilities.
- Hello.
- You briefly touched upon this
subject on your presentation.
So the nice thing
with the theremin
is that you can play all
frequencies and no notes.
But this makes it,
also, very hard.
So is there any
space for basically
mapping different positions
to just a specific scale
so that it's more
easy for somebody
to play on top of a song, to
play a solo, or to make music?
- You mean without
connecting the notes?
Is that what you mean?
If you asked me to
play more staccato?
I'm trying to understand
your question.
- So instead of having,
now, this antenna, which
maps through all frequencies,
to say I don't know,
like from this capacity
to this capacity,
it's going to be this note.
And I'm only going to have
a specific chromatic scale
or something that
matches the music.
- That is a technical question
that's very interesting.
Maybe--
- Oh, no.
I think-- I'm sure
this can be done.
But the question is if you would
be interested in doing that.
Because you would
be limiting yourself
to just playing specific
notes that you allow yourself.
Because anything
you play will be
matching this part of the song.
But it would make it much
easier for any novice to play.
- Well, it's really
interesting what you're saying.
You should go and work for
Moog Music immediately.
They want you.
Because that's what
this instrument--
that's actually a new
invention that this instrument
brought to the market.
And these thereminis,
they do exactly that.
You can set the range,
and you can set the key.
And when you turn
the pitch control on,
you play along to a song.
So I can have 10 four-year-olds
in a circle playing
10 theremins.
They're all on the same setting,
and they play Kraftwerk,
and it sounds perfectly in key.
It's a miracle.
Because the wrong
notes are filtered out.
It's exactly what
you're describing.
That was their idea.
They came up with
that two years ago.
And a lot of thereminists
were really angry
when this came on the market.
And also, when
things are not fully
established yet, a lot of
people kind of hoarding it
and want it all to
themselves, like I'm the--
and I really believe that we
need inclusivity and community.
And the more people, the more
it can grow into a movement.
And so this instrument
really makes
that bridge of having
an easy result.
Because it is really,
really hard to play.
So it sounds good.
You have the filter, the
few notes that fit, exactly,
a scale.
And then, if you
really go further,
you can turn it
off and go on so.
Yeah.
Amazing.
That's exactly what
they came up with.
- So you approve of it?
You approve of this?
- Yes.
I approve of it for teaching.
And yes.
That's really what the
Moog people came up with,
and you just had the same idea.
- OK.
Thanks.
- Excellent.
Wow.
- Thank you very much.
I actually have a question
for your science colleague,
if that's all right.
- OK.
You're putting me on the spot.
- And it may seem a
little far afield,
but listening to
your presentation,
I've always been a
fan of the theremin,
especially the years I
was living in Budapest.
But I'm very interested in what
you said about the early use
for spycraft.
And thinking about the recent
microwave problems in Havana,
could you please
help us understand
if that's related to this?
Or is there anything you
can offer to us about that?
- Well, I don't know much--
let me say one thing I missed
at the beginning.
I just wanted to sort of fill
out what I should have said.
So this alarm that
Dorit mentioned,
it's a whole class of sensors
called proximity sensors.
And that was the alarm
that used-- so, in a sense,
you could never enter a
room without broadcasting
your presence in an
electromagnetic sense.
And so the idea of
these alarm systems
was using the
capacitance of your body
to basically set off the alarm.
And so that's what got
him thinking about how
to do this as a theremin.
I don't know exactly--
we don't know exactly--
what was going on
with the embassies.
But we do know that microwaves--
just look at what happens
in the oven, right?
You put something in
the oven, and the way
a microwave oven works is that
there is a certain frequency
that excites water molecules.
And it's close to a certain
microwave frequency.
So if you have a microwave
oscillator called a klystron,
and it's tuned to the frequency
of this vibrational state
in water, it'll heat it up.
And so our bodies are
mostly made out of water.
So if you focus a microwave
beam at that frequency
and point it at somebody,
you can basically
kill them, or give them
a substantial disruption.
So my guess-- and I don't
know because, clearly, it's
classified-- is that there was
some sort of focused microwave
beam that was developed
by the Russians,
and then they decided to
test drive it in Havana.
That's my best guess.
- The reason I raised it--
it seems very far afield--
is that the first symptoms
were about ringing and hearing
sounds.
And I thought maybe
that was related.
- Well, I don't know.
It could be.
Now that you mention
it, I did see that.
And so I don't know.
It could have been
some sort of modulation
that used some sort of a
resonant frequency in the head.
Like, maybe what you can do
is tune it until you get--
you know, when we
produce voices,
we have different vowel sounds.
And the vowel sounds
get varied because we
have the pharynx
as one resonance
and then, depending on where
the tongue is in your mouth,
we get another resonance.
And then, the nasal
cavities have yet another.
So it's conceivable that maybe
what they're trying to do
is to make the resonances,
our body resonances,
go nuts or something.
- OK.
Thank you.
- It's a guess.
- I imagine with AI,
you could probably
get a lot of different
robots doing these things.
And wouldn't it be
possible to visualize
the function of their
systems, the function
of our different systems, and
the function of the instrument?
- I'm not sure exactly--
you mean trying to have
a mathematical model or
a simulation of that?
- Right.
Plot the differences
so you can analyze it.
- Oh, yeah.
So I don't know.
Has anybody produced a robot
who can play the theremin?
- I've been
fantasizing about this
and started to work
with someone on that.
But it's a long-term project.
But yeah.
It doesn't-- not to my
knowledge that it exists,
but I think it should exist.
Because you could play, maybe,
really well because you would
have really stable movements.
- Right.
So what you could do--
I'm just riffing on this--
but I could imagine.
- What would you do
with understanding
the difference and the
functions of the system, anyway?
- Well, I think that you would
get much more precise control
over the sounds.
Because what would
happen would be,
there's a certain
feedback between--
I'd have to ask a
performance artist--
but I would imagine that there's
some feedback between what
you're hearing and
where the hand is.
And so if your hand's a
little off in frequency,
you would alter it until it
hits the right frequencies.
And I would imagine, perhaps,
with a robot, because their CPU
cycles are so much faster, that
they could hit more precisely
and more quickly that note and
might not have to fall back
on vibrato to tune things.
- Well, we tested it
with some automated hand,
like robot machine hands.
But it became
apparent very quickly
that that specific model was
moving too coarse and too fast
and too jagged.
I'm talking European
measurements now.
We're talking about
millimeter distances.
So I'm sure it could be done.
But when I tried it
out, that robot hand
couldn't master the theremin.
- Yeah.
So that's an interesting
thought for the future.
- Well, I was just
wondering, through that kind
of creativity, could you
find any new information
about creativity or physics?
- Information about the
creative process, for example?
Yeah.
Could be.
There are some interesting--
I don't know it in
a musical context,
but there is a deep learning
project called DeepDream
that Google has.
And what it does is it tries
to do pattern recognition
and then impose or
reimpose on the image
that it's been given new
images and twist it around.
So if you actually google the
word DeepDream, what you can do
is you can take an image,
deposit it, and then
it'll run its algorithm and
try to do pattern recognition.
And so if you take something
like a rocky cliff face
or kind of the jagged
structure of a gnarly tree
and you put it through there
several times, what'll emerge
are the faces of birds
or dogs or reptiles.
Because the training set
that's been used on that
is sort of keyed in
to dogs and reptiles
and that sort of thing.
So you can imagine
that if you trained
some sort of deep
learning project
and you've perfected a robot
that actually can do it
without these problems,
you could imagine
that it would impose
its own aesthetic
and make its own
compositions, which
is sort of what the deep
learning is getting to.
But it's not quite there.
So I would say the robotics
is not up to the task yet.
And the deep learning is
not up to the task yet.
But you could imagine that,
at some point in the future,
the combination of
the two could produce
its own creative, non-human
way of producing music.
- Last question?
- Could you tell a
little more about--
I understand that
he married a dancer
and then tried to
see if a dancer could
dance within a field.
- Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
Lev Theremin, while
he was in New York,
he also worked on
the terpsitone, which
is a theremin made for dancers.
And maybe it was inspired by
his wife, Lavinia Williams.
But it seemed that nobody really
could control the terpsitone.
Because again, the
body would just
move too much to really turn
it into a melodic device.
There is, right now, a
project in Paris premiering
at the Pompidou.
And I'm very happy about it.
It features seven terpsitones
and three dancers.
And I was helping with
the consultation--
because they really didn't
understand it's all about
calibrating the theremin, like
setting the size of the fields
which you can do of the
pitch of the volume--
and so help them
to understand which
distances work for them and
the kind of things they can do.
So it's ambitiously
being applied again.
But to turn that musical
is very difficult.
One of my favorite inventions
that Lev Theremin also did,
aside from all the
things we mentioned,
is the rhythmicon, which is
a huge, clunky rhythm machine
that couldn't hold the beat.
I think that's very--
and it sounds like a
Frankenstein device.
Anyway, any other questions?
Oh, thank you.
- Well, I have to
say without hyperbole
that the theremin is cool.
That was great.
[APPLAUSE]
I'd like to thank John.
Thank you, John, for
being the science guy
and explaining to us how this
marvelous piece of equipment--
beautiful machine-- works.
And Dorit, you're amazing.
That was fantastic.
Thank you for sharing
the theremin with us.
And thank you all for coming.
And make sure you register
for the other lectures
in the Series for
the Undiscovered.
And given the
enthusiasm today, I
think it's going to be a great
year for the Radcliffe events.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]